this morning we begin in edinburgh
scotland where queen elizabeth ii is
lying at rest just minutes ago
procession brought her coffin from
hollywood house that's the official
royal residence in edinburgh to st giles
cathedral
king charles and other royals took part
in this procession on saturday charles
iii was officially proclaimed king
during a very ornate ceremony at st
james palace in london that ceremony was
repeated yesterday in scotland wales in
northern ireland the other nations of
the united kingdom and this morning
prince harry released his first public
statement about his grandmother who he
lovingly calls granny we'll have more on
that in just a moment right now cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
that of course is nora o'donnell is
leading our coverage from london she's
outside buckingham palace along with a
huge crowd of mourners nora good morning
the crowd keeps growing and growing good
to see you
oh my goodness gail you should see it
it's unbelievable the amount of people
that have come to pay their respects and
will continue to
for the next following days it's already
been a busy day here in london we've now
seen the king several times of course in
scotland as you just
referenced and there's a lot of new
details about what's to come
the queen will remain at st giles
cathedral overnight and members of the
public will be allowed in to pay their
respects starting about an hour from now
that follows the very elaborate and
carefully planned procession with the
new king you'll remember the queen died
at her home in scotland a place she
loved so dearly and that is why this
week-long series of events leading up to
next week's funeral began there
elizabeth palmer is at the royal
residence in edinburgh elizabeth good
morning
this is the first day that members of
the public will be able to file past the
queen's coffin to pay their respects
it's just one component and a very
complex series of rights associated with
the funeral and also the transition to
the new monarch
in london this morning the new king
charles iii met members of the house of
commons and the house of lords
it is a loss to all of us
but we know
most of all
it is a loss to you your majesty and to
the royal family he accepted their
condolences in westminster hall the room
where his mother's body will lie in
state later in the week
afterwards king charles set off to
edinburgh where he and members of the
royal family followed the queen's coffin
to the cathedral in a solemn procession
along the historic road known as the
royal mile
yesterday he was proclaimed king here in
scotland that the prince
charles philip arthur george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign happy
of memory
become our only lawful
and rightful liege lord
charles iii
god save the king
just over 24 hours ago the queen's
hearse left balmoral her private country
estate the coffin draped in the scottish
standard flag
the procession wound its way through the
scottish countryside well-wishers lining
the route on horseback and even in
tractors to say goodbye
by late afternoon crowds had packed the
streets of the capitol to pay their
respects
i think it's just important to be here
just important to say goodbye what was
so remarkable about her well she started
at really young age and she did do a lot
of impact and now that she's like going
to be gone there's going to it's going
to be different it's never going to be
the same again quite speechless actually
she was a lovely lady
great mother grandmother and
she did well the queen was connected to
the scottish people not only as their
sovereign but also as their country
woman she herself was descended from
scottish kings
yesterday afternoon three of the queen's
children princess anne and princess
andrew and edward were waiting at the
door as their mother arrived at
hollywood house for the last time
as we saw the queen's body left
hollyrood house the royal residence a
short time ago
she will lie at rest in saint giles's
cathedral until tomorrow and after a
religious ceremony today the royal
family will hold a formal vigil over the
body nora
elizabeth palmer in edinburgh for us
thank you and